[Music]
hey pop hmm that's your question how
come you never liked me likee what law
is there say I got to like you no all
right then
don't you eat every day answer me when I
talk to you don't you eat every day yeah
as long as you in my house you put a
cell on the end of it when you talk to
me yes sir you eat every day yes sir got
a roof over your head yes sir I clothes
on your back yes sir why you think that
is cuz he hell I know it's cuz of me but
why do you think that is cuz you like me
like you I go out of here every morning
I bust my butt
cuz I like you you're about the biggest
fool ever saw a man is supposed to take
care of his family
you live in my house for your belly with
my food put your behind on my bed
because you're my son
it's my duty to take care of you I hope
on sibility to you I ain't got to like
you now I don't give you everything I
got to give you I give you your life me
and your mama work that up between us
and like in your black ass wasn't part
of the bargain now don't you go through
life worrying about whether somebody
like you or not you best be making sure
that they're doing right by you you
understand what I'm saying
everything that boy do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years understanding with you I get 18
years of my life to stand in the same
spot as you and trained you can